[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 les invités une
émission pour découvrir celles et ceux
qui font l'actualité dans le département
et ce soir parole à michel de kerchove
la présidente de france victime on va
parler avec elle du lancement d'une
nouvelle application et des mois une
application pourrait aider et guider les
victimes et le grand public dans leurs
démarches
dans cette émission vous entendrez aussi
joséphine comme man ce berger la mer les
républicains deux plaisirs qui
présentera elle les grands projets de
2017 pour sa commune mais on débute donc
cette émission avec michel de kharkov
qui nous a rejoints en plateau bonsoir
dans sa présidente de france victime je
disais france victime du coup qui
remplace enseignement l'inavem c'est
l'une des nouveautés aussi de de cette
fin d'année pour vous c'est ça tout à
fait il nous a semblé nécessaire d'avoir
une appellation beaucoup plus visible et
lisible pour toutes les victimes qui
peuvent avoir besoin de nous je rappelle
que sont à la fois les victimes d
infractions courant de la vie mais
également les victimes d'accidents
collectifs et des victimes d'attentats
bien évidemment donc le terme france
victime parlera beaucoup plus à tout le
monde à tout public le terme in avait
donc pour l'instant vous connaît encore
sous le nom d' inavem oiseuses victimes
mais vous allez vous appelez france
victimes par exemple 78 oui on le sait
que toutes les associations de france
victime dans france il ya 130
associations et bien prendre ont petit à
petit le numéro du département derrière
ford victime et nous serons france
victime 70
en tout cas c'est un nouveau nom mais
france victime est une association qui
existe depuis maintenant 30 ans 30 ans
30 ans que vous venez donc en aide aux
victimes vous en parliez juste une
nouvelle précision sur ce mot victime
c'est un mois si on va dire global
qu'est-ce qui est concerné par votre
association pas uniquement d'ailleurs
des victimes si j'ai bien compris ça
peut être les proches des victimes a
bien sûr mais ce sont des victimes comme
on dit du second cercle ce sont ceux qui
ont subi également ce qui a été fait à
leurs proches donc les victimes de ce ça
peut être les enfants en cas d'un drap m
familiale ça peut être les proches dans
le cadre d'un attentat ceux qui ont
perdu quelqu'un ou ceux qui aident ceux
qui ont été gravement touchée par ces
attentats
votre actualité aussi c'est le lancement
du coût de cette application et des mois
une application pour smartphone qui va
permettre à ces victimes et au grand
public d'être guidés dans leurs
différentes démarches est ce que vous
pouvez nous préciser l'utilité qu'est ce
qu'on va retrouver sur cette application
qu'on voit à l'écran alors l'objectif
cette application c'est que tout le
monde sans attendre d'être victime
télécharger cette application de manière
à ce que le jour où malheureusement ils
devront faire appel à des services de
police de gendarmerie des services
médicaux et une association d'aidé aux
victimes
ils ont tout de suite les coordonnées
sans être obligé de chercher dans
l'annuaire se renseigner sur
l'application pascal géolocalisation qui
va permettre donc d'identifier où il se
trouve
et là il va voir tous les numéros qui
vont apparaître de tous les services
dont ils peuvent avoir besoin pour
pouvoir prendre en charge leur situation
il faudra j'imagine ce guide et en
répondant à quelques questions types de
d'agression ou tout à l'agent de grève
simplement mais néanmoins toutes les
informations seront données il ya les
numéros d'urgence et à la possibilité
d'être mise en relation immédiatement
avec tous ces services est également
avec nos associations celle qui sera la
plus proche de l'endroit qui vous êtes
concernera on y trouve aussi des
conseils psychologiques des
renseignements sur sur nos droits en cas
en cas d'agression par exemple ou en cas
d'autres notre malheur qui peuvent
souvent arrivé à la fin toujours être
prudent avec les conseils qui puisse
être donnée de cette façon là il faut
bien sûr se rapprocher d'abord des
professionnels donc dans les
associations vous trouverez des
psychologues
vous trouverez des juristes des
travailleurs sociaux qui permettent
effectivement de se retrouver dans la
situation où on est il ya tellement de
démarches à faire on est tellement perdu
quand ça nous arrive que si on a
quelqu'un pour vous guider et pour vous
faciliter les choses c'est quelque chose
de formidable
alors on comprend ce volet simplifier la
vie mais aussi est ce que l'objectif de
cette application c'est de faire passer
cette première étape de de parler de
dire de faire la démarche d'aller voir
quelqu'un même si c'est via le numérique
mais passé c'est toute cette gêne
parfois d'aller dénoncer un tel ou de
parler de ce qui nous est arrivé alors
l'intérêt c'est qu'il ya la possibilité
de te joindre très rap
man au moins le numéro national du 08
victime qui lui est ouvert 7 jours sur 7
ce qui permet d'avoir une première
écoute qui parfois est suffisante pour
rassurer et pour orienter et ensuite
d'aller vers l'association qui est
territorialement compétentes de notre
situation il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont victimes de drames dans la vie et
qui n'ose pas en parler mais ça concerne
beaucoup de beaucoup de gens bien sûr
bien sûr il ya toujours effectivement ce
barrage de l'identification les
personnes ne préfère en nous nos
services sont confidentiels
donc on peut s'adresser à quelqu'un on
peut appeler 08 victimes sans donner son
identité
et là on aura une écoute bienveillante
qui peut durer plusieurs minutes me voir
plus si la personne en a besoin et ça
peut être suffisant après on essaye de
les guider les orienter pour que
finalement leur situation soit prise en
charge le mieux possible cette première
étape de dire ce qui s'est passé de
raconter de chercher des conseils c'est
la plus importante quand on cherche
importante verbaliser ce que l'on
ressent ce que l'on a vécu
et puis après d'avoir quelqu'un en face
de vous qui vous donne un accompagnement
humain c'est à dire vous n'êtes pas un
objet qui est l'objet de procédures
judiciaires vous n'êtes pas un objet
entre lehmann médecins qui vont vous
traitez comme un patient vous êtes un
être humain et vous avez en face de vous
un autre être humain qui lui va prendre
la distance nécessaire pour vous guider
dans ce que vous devez faire pour la
suite de vos opérations vous le disiez
vous l'avais dit en introduction et des
mois cette application il faut que ce
soit pour que ça marche réellement que
tout le monde la télécharge tout le
monde ment pas c'est gratuit
elle est gratuite donc accessible très
facilement sur tous les smartphones donc
il faut effectivement la télécharger la
faire connaître à vos enfants à tout le
monde
il faut que vous l'ayez sur vous parce
que c'est ça peut sauver la vie
quel jeune à l'abri aussi pour le
rappeler on n'est jamais à l'abri d'être
victime d'un jour mais ça peut sauver
aussi la vie de quelqu'un parfois si on
a quelqu'un côté de soi qui est ainsi
des difficultés si on à l'application
sur soi et bien on peut tout de suite
prévenir également les services de
secours disponibles cette application
sur android et apple store blues
tout à fait je voudrais maintenant vous
faire réagir et pour terminer cet
entretien sur une autre actualité
concernant l'aide aux victimes et la
création en janvier par l'état d'un
secrétariat général à l'aide aux
victimes c'est un nouvelle
outil en plus du secrétariat aussi qui
existe désormais d'état des deux
victimes
les choses bougent pour l'aide aux
victimes est ce que tout ça selon vous
va dans le bon sens j'imagine que oui
mais est-ce que vous avez satisfait de
tout ce qui est mise en place jours
c'est vrai c'est vrai que
malheureusement les attentats nous ont
beaucoup aidés pour cela ça a suscité la
création de ce secrétariat d'état mais
c'est un outil politique le secrétariat
d'état donc on ne sait jamais si ça va
être reconduit l'année prochaine et les
années ensuite une autre avec les
élections qui arrivent
voilà justement alors que justement ce
secrétariat général est eu plutôt une
administration qui si elle est créée va
permettre de coordonner les actions de
tous les ministères parce qu'on sait
qu'il n'ya pas que le ministère de la
justice où le ministère de l'intérieur
qui sont concernés ils amistad
transports au ministère des affaires
étrangères donc ça permet une
coordination que la secrétaire d'état
qui a été nommé en février a pu assurer
avec son rôle politique et il y aura une
instance interministérielle mais ça
c'est l'avenir qui nous dira si elle est
maintenue qui permettra de réunir aussi
les ministères par de temps en temps au
tour d'une table pour définir la
politique qui doit être mené en matière
d'aidé aux victimes
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui le
dispositif des deux victimes est complet
en france oui encore et encore des mains
des manques spécifiques
alors il n'est jamais complète d'une
part parce qu'on n'arrive pas à toucher
toutes les victimes il ya encore
beaucoup de victimes qui se sont encore
isolées et abandonné d'où l'intérêt de
cette application est de notre nouvelle
bannière france victime pour se faire
mieux connaître
donc ça c'est une première chose ensuite
il faut pour renforcer encore nos
équipes pour pouvoir accueillir ses
victimes
mais il ya eu une véritable évolution
ces cinq dernières années il faut le
souligner qui ont permis de renforcer
nos équipes les budgets ont été
augmentés ce secrétariat d'état inter
ministériel qu'on appelait nos voeux
depuis 30 ans il a alors revu les
attentats pour pour le faire mais c'est
une bonne chose tout de même mieux vaut
tard qu'une évolution que j'en avais
quand même régressé beaucoup auparavant
on rappelle le nom de l'application et
des mois est disponible sur android et
apple store merci michel de kharkov
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes la présidente de
france victime
on poursuit ce 7,8 les invités avec la
ville de plaisir et sa mère joséphine
coleman ce berger qui a présenté à la
presse il y a quelques jours les projets
phares de la commune
pour l'an prochain rd 30 nouveaux
centres culturels ou travaux dans le
centre ville
les précisions au micro d'haussmann
thunder des la plaisir on a aujourd'hui
trois grands axes qui sont importants on
a le premier axe qui est la
requalification du centre-ville inquiète
une projection sur les vingt trente
années à venir
nous présenterons d'ailleurs à la
population un projet sur lequel nous
travaillons depuis deux ans il y aura
une concertation avec la population pour
leur présenter la prospective de notre
centre ville mais sans trop bling pas
historique centre une beaucoup plus
large sur plaisir nous aurons également
une grande étude urbaine qui va
commencer à se structurer tout autour de
la scène commerciale puisque le fait que
la rd30 aujourd'hui commence à jouer
dira a maturé et que l'année prochaine
ça complètement terminée et bien autour
de toute cette zone la zone commerciale
opensky qui va les travaux ont commencé
avec et celle du cinéma les commerces
puis un lieu de vie véritable au chant
et d'allemand qui va se modifier
complètement devant la gare de plaisir
des claies tout ça fait partie d'une
étude urbaine très important sur
laquelle nous travaillons aussi depuis
un an et qui aujourd'hui va aboutir à
des résultats et des phasages de mines
en opération
donc ça c'est deux choses déjà très très
important la troisième chose eh bien
c'est un projet que nous avons évoqué
avec les plaisirs aux alors de notre
mandature
quand on est arrivés sur cette
responsabilité qui est la mienne
aujourd'hui avec l'équipe
c'est ce centre culturel que nous allons
mettre en place dans les communs du
château
on a un très gros projet qui dans le
cadre des contrats départementaux et
s'éteint
aussi un lieu de vie dans lequel il y
aura bibliothèque et vidéothèque
numérique également le conservatoire qui
vint s'installer dans un château mais
aussi un lieu de vie d'accueil avec les
gens qui voudront se poser et être là et
profiter de ce centre à l'intérieur des
communs du château donc on travaille en
partenariat étroit avec bien sûr
l'architecte des monuments de france
avec aussi la drieu avec aussi la cie a
eu lieu qui va nous accompagner sur
l'environnement au niveau du parc parce
que c'est important
voilà trois grands axes fondamentaux de
2017 et des années qui suivent on a
aussi bien sûr toujours une gestion
super rigoureuse à plaisir puisque avec
les pertes de dotation et bien on est
dans cette démarche là une démarche
d'économie permanente d'ailleurs je
présente demain soir le budget 2010 est
à la ville qui est un budget en
progression et justement parce que nous
avons mis en place des économies très
forte et très substantiel aussi parce
que nous nous sommes débarrassés des
fameux emprunts toxiques qui avait été
pris en 2008 donc j'en suis ravi ça nous
apporte un vrai soulagement par rapport
à ces emprunts toxiques qui nous
impacter beaucoup au niveau financier
donc on est dans des démarches comme
vous voyez importante pas des démarches
séquentiel mais des démarches de fond
sur sur le territoire et puis bien sûr
il ya 50 ans et ville puisque nous
sommes rentrés dans saint quentin en
yvelines et donc il ya tout ce travail
de préparation
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
nouvelle édition demain même heure en
attendant retrouvez toutes nos séquences
sur tv fil 78 points comme bonne soirée
à tous
[Musique]